la crisis económica y de los bancos en
Líbano está afectando a todo el mundo
incluso a los políticos este miércoles
la diputada Cintia zaracín entró a la
sucursal de biblos Bank acerca de la
capital Con un objetivo exigir 8.500
dólares de sus ahorros para una cirugía
médica todo tras una semana con evasivas
por parte del banco
sus llamadas al banco sus intentos por
concretar una cita el gerente
dirigiéndola al centro de llamadas y el
centro de llamadas devolviendolas
pero la cirugía de Cintia es muy urgente
varias horas después acompañada por sus
abogados y después de amenazar con hacer
una sentada con el director del banco
dentro para hacer consiguió el dinero
para su operación
quiero decir que este es el caso de
todos los depositantes y ciudadanos
libaneses Esta es la humillación a la
que Hemos llegado en este país
pero los derechos no mueren estamos aquí
exigiendo nuestros derechos y Seguiremos
pidiéndolos aquí y en el parlamento
Y es que los bancos con problemas de
liquidez están bloqueando los ahorros de
sus clientes con muchas limitaciones
para retirar efectivo algo que ha
desecado en protestas y también en
constantes asaltos bancarios solo el
martes se registraron 4
queremos que el gobernador del Banco
Central del Líbano orgia nuestra voz
roba al Estado robo en nuestro dinero y
legalizó el robo del dinero de los
depositantes
junto al descontento de la población que
ha visto como los niveles de pobreza se
han disparado en el país la crisis
económica también aumenta con el paso de
los días